[Music]  sonic meet knuckles  you're no match for me  nailed it to face a new enemy you are  really bad at punching sonic will need a  fresh new look i make this look good  a ride or die crew uh did your butt just  turn into a helicopter  and laser focus you got a little  something on your feet  let's get out of here  oh great the winter soldier sonic the  hedgehog 2 coming soon let's do this  i make this look good  how's it going bud everything here is  completely normal  this year i will destroy this planet you  can run faster gotta go fast  fly higher  did your butt just turn into a  helicopter yeah and a bunch harder  for a guy named knuckles you are really  bad at punching  the hedgehog coming soon  that wasn't too bad  we need to defeat robotnik and knuckles  i'm all powerful what the world is doing  it's a race say goodbye here we go  oh lord there are two of them now  destroyed  oh great the winter soldier  [Music]  bye